bonjour et bienvenue dans check-up le
magazine santé de la rédaction au
sommaire tout d'abord le cancer du sein
repérez tôt il est curable dans 90% des
cas une opération pour inciter les
femmes à se faire dépister un lieu à
Trappes faut-il allaiter ou non son
enfant c'est une question que peuvent se
poser les futurs maman nous écouterons
la vie d'une conseillère en lactation
installée à Montigny prévenir plutôt que
guérir c'est le credo de la CPAM des
Yvelines à travers ses ateliers Santé
Active d'abord lancer à Poissy ils sont
mis en place depuis le 6 novembre dans
l'agglomération 5 continents mais
d'abord peut-être avez-vous été frappé
par ce drame qui s'est déroulé et dans
le Lot une future maman a perdu son
enfant parce qu'elle n'a pas pu
atteindre la maternité alors cela a posé
dans un premier temps la question des
déserts médicaux l'association
UFC de choisir à lancer une vaste
enquête et dresser la carte sanitaire de
la France et vous allez voir que les
Yvelines ne sont pas épargnées les
Yvelines n'est pas un département
protégé
pas que je sache manque de médecins
dépassement d'honoraires l'association
IFC Que Choisir tirent la sonnette
d'alarme récent rapport dresse une carte
de la fracture sanitaire en France et le
département n'est pas épargné notamment
par les déserts médicaux même sur 50 ans
en Yvelines les chiffres sont éloquents
en ce qui concerne le nombre de médecins
généralistes sur l'agglomération le
ratio est de 29,3 mètres alors qu'il est
de 70 attrapes et UFC Que Choisir c'est
aussi intéressé à trois spécialités
dites en accès libre l'ophtalmologie la
pédiatrie et la gynécologie il manque
des gynécologues sur les Yvelines comme
beaucoup dans beaucoup d'endroits ils
dépassent les honoraires ou n'ouvrent
plus à la clientèle dans le département
les dépassements d'honoraires concernent
sur tout le sud des Yvelines des
secteurs comme chevreuses ou Rambouillet
un accord national décrit comme
historique a été trouvé le 23 octobre le
seuil de dépassement est limité à 150%
UFC Que Choisir souhaiterait plafonner
se dépassement à 40%, une moyenne
nationale prise en compte par les
mutuelles les professionnels et le
gouvernement sont passés à 150% avec
diminution possible sur trois ans or on
sait très bien connaissant l'esprit
français que ça ne se fera pas et ça
risque d'inciter au contraire les
professionnels de santé à rechercher des
secteurs bien dotés déjà et de prendre
des dépassements encore plus faramineux
entre les médecins qui désertent
certains quartiers et les dépassements
d'honoraires l'association de
consommateurs préconise des aides
spécifiques pour permettre aux médecins
de s'installer dans des zones
identifiées et de limiter les
implantations dans des zones dites
surdotées
un cancer du sein détecté tôt et curable
dans 90% des cas en France depuis 2004
les femmes de 50 à 74 ans peuvent
bénéficier d'un dépistage gratuit dans
les Yvelines les femmes sont plutôt
réticentes à bénéficier de ces
mammographies de contrôle alors je vous
propose tout de suite de regarder une
opération plutôt originale cela s'est
déroulé à Trappes une compagnie de
théâtre est venue faire passer le
message
c'est vrai que j'adore rire et blaguer
mais il y a des moments il faut savoir
être sérieux surtout quand il s'agit du
cancer du sein si vous êtes une femme de
plus de 50 ans vous allez recevoir une
lettre pour vous faire dépister prenez
rendez-vous vous avez peut-être vu cette
publicité diffusée en ce moment Nagui
qui se prononce pour le dépistage du
cancer du sein une campagne nationale
pour inciter les femmes entre 5 ans et
74 ans à bénéficier du dépistage gratuit
et sur le terrain une mobilisation
également locale comme ici à Trappes
avec l'opération des parapluies roses on
invite les femmes à se faire dépister
parce que en fait on s'aperçoit qu'on
dans les Yvelines on est un département
où 41% seulement des femmes participent
à ce dépistage organisés donc il y a des
gens qui sont réticents il y en a qui il
y en a qui ont peur parce que le cancer
est un mot qui fait peur donc nous on
essaye simplement de
dédramatiser et de leur dire que
justement avec le avec le dépistage
c'est pas forcément la maladie c'est
c'est justement en s'y prenant parfois
tôt que un cancer a été plus cancer des
pistetto plus on le soigne des comédiens
sont donc venus raconter des histoires
pour faire passer un seul message
détecter tôt 90% des cancers du sein
sont guéris avec près de 53000 nouveaux
cas chaque année le cancer du sein et le
cancer le plus fréquent chez la femme
dans les Yvelines un centre de
coordination est basé au Chesnay
allaiter ou non son enfant c'est une
question que peuvent être amenées à se
poser les futurs maman parce que souvent
dans l'idée l'allaitement ça ne rime pas
avec vie professionnelle et bien pour
répondre à cette question nous sommes
allés demander son avis à une
conseillère en lactation installée à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
un personnel hospitalier débordé un
congé maternité court et des femmes qui
travaillent autant de raisons qui
freinent la mise au sein des bambins et
même si la France reste à la traîne
certaines femmes vont jusqu'au bout de
leur désir d'allaiter et assume leur
choix comme ces mamans rencontrées lors
d'une réunion à Versailles c'était
familial à la base enfin toute ma
famille allaiter et puis après j'ai
compris que c'était plus simple pour le
bébé et puis plus
naturel ça lui donnait tout et puis bon
en tant que jeune je pense qu'on est
toutes les trois là on se connaît toutes
faites il y a quand même un aspect
budget c'est bête mais ça fait réfléchir
je me voyais pas faire autrement en fait
enfin c'était la dans la continuité de
la grossesse et
voilà pour créer du lien avec ma fille
pour je sais pas enfin c'était juste
naturel mais pas aussi simple que ça les
études démontrent que les femmes qui
font le choix de l'allaitement ont pour
la plupart fait des études supérieures
et sont indépendantes
difficile alors de concilier réussite
professionnelle et vie de famille
pourtant certaines y parviennent elles
seront capables de dire mais moi ça me
plaît et je veux le beurre et l'argent
du beurre c'est à dire je veux continuer
mon métier reprendre mon travail
continuez à l'été Mon enfant et elle ne
se laisse pas abattre par exemple à la
reprise du travail afin d'être mieux
informé les futurs mamans se tournent
vers des associations spécialisées ou
écoutes et échanges d'expérience les
ratures
prévenir plutôt que guérir c'est le
credo de la CPAM désigne à travers ses
ateliers Santé Active autour de thèmes
comme la nutrition le cœur le dos et ses
ateliers débutent justement à 50 ans en
Yvelines
et si la Caisse Primaire d'Assurance
Maladie changeait de nom pour s'appeler
caisse primaire d'assurance santé si au
lieu de rembourser les soins elle les
prévenaient une idée toute simple mise
en place dans le département d'abord à
Poissy et prochainement à 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est l'opération Santé Active
ouverte à tous les assurés sociaux du
régime général des ateliers collectifs
proposés autour de trois thématiques le
cœur le dos et la nutrition il s'agit de
proposer un service de coaching en santé
alors le coaching en santé qu'est-ce que
c'est en fait c'est accompagner au
quotidien des personnes qui ne sont pas
malades pour préserver leur capital
santé c'est lié effectivement à
l'évolution des dépenses de santé et
aujourd'hui à des pathologies qu'on voit
croissantes par exemple si on regarde la
pathogie du diabète on voit qu'il y a
une augmentation croissante et les
courbes d'évolution montrent que d'ici à
quelques années le nombre de personnes
diabétiques pourra presque tripler à 50
ans en Yvelines le dispositif est pour
l'instant expérimental les ateliers vont
démarrer à partir du innovembre la
prévention primaire le but étant de
passer des informations générales à la
base et de donner des outils par le
biais des ateliers avec des on a des
ateliers théoriques et des ateliers
pratiques donc justement des mises en
condition je passe je pense surtout à
l'activité physique ou là par contre la
personne va être acteur pendant son
atelier ces ateliers de prévention sont
gratuits l'opération Santé Active a été
mise en place il y a 5 mois sur le
territoire de Poissy et la CPAM
enregistrait 450 adhérents une étude
interne démontrerait qu'un tel
dispositif étendu à l'échelle nationale
pourrait permettre à l'Assurance Maladie
de réaliser 200 millions d'euros
d'économies
vous le voyez derrière moi c'est le
château de la cool
dramontigny-le-bretonneux château qui
est accueilli pendant plusieurs années
les services de la Communauté
d'Agglomération service transféré depuis
quelques mois à Trappes et bien dans ces
locaux pour être s'installer une maison
de retraite en 2014 on regarde
à presque 150 ans le château de La
Coudre pourrait bien s'offrir une
seconde vie après avoir accueilli la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin la commune de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux s'est portée
candidate pour transformer cette demeure
en EHPAD cette candidature trouve sa
cause dans les migrations des inondains
aujourd'hui une partie des personnes
retraitées des ménages intra-muros
passant d'un pavillon à un appartement
de là est né l'idée d'une résidence
service accompagnant un EHPAD cette
installation sera divisée en deux
parties les services administratifs et
sociaux seront installés dans le château
l'autre partie la résidence service
dédiée aux personnes plus autonomes sera
construite à l'entrée du site la
capacité de l'accueil donc de la
résidence service et environ une
soixantaine de logements et les pâtes
donc sera de 84 lits 80 en hébergement
complet et 4 lits à temps à hébergement
partiel c'est-à-dire des hébergements
temporaires soit pour permettre du répit
soit un retour d'hôpital pour
accompagner les personnes une convention
devrait être signée avec l'hôpital de
plaisir pour prendre en charge les
personnes âgées devant être
hospitalisées le seul point
d'interrogation réside dans la présence
ou non d'autres projets pour le site du
château de La Coudre dont le parc sera
toujours ouvert au public Simoncini
remporte l'appel d'offres du conseil
général l'EPAD pourrait ouvrir ses
portes fin 2014
allez avant de nous quitter cette
information concernant la grippe le
vaccin anti-grippe est disponible depuis
à la mi-octobre dans les pharmacies la
Caisse Primaire d'Assurance Maladie fait
parvenir à ses assurés des bons de prise
en charge pour leur permettre de les
retirer gratuitement dans les officines
dans le département plus de 215 000
assurés sont concernés par cette mesure
ce sont les plus de 65 ans les personnes
atteintes d'affection de longues durées
ou étant entouré de nourrissons de moins
de 6 mois cette année les femmes
enceintes et les personnes souffrant
d'une forte obésité sont également
invités à se faire vacciner voilà pour
l'information sur le vaccin anti-grippe
notez maintenant ces rendez-vous santé
le Conseil général des Yvelines organise
une journée d'échanges et d'informations
sur les pratiques et les missions des
centres de planification et d'éducation
familiale c'est un lieu de ressources
pour la sexualité des jeunes une réunion
a lieu le 12 novembre notez également
que l'antenne de France Alzheimer de 50
ans en Yvelines propose plusieurs
formations gratuite pour les aidants
familiaux ces formations sont assurées
notamment par un par un psychologue et
puis plusieurs ateliers santé actifs
proposés par la scpm on en a parlé dans
cette émission ces ateliers ont lieu à
l'IPS à l'Institut de promotion de la
santé à Trappes autour de thème comme
bien manger bien bouger ou encore
consommé malin check-up c'est fini merci
de votre attention prochain numéro le 7
décembre d'ici là portez-vous bien